[Music]
well so so so many people did you see
Jessica's talk about comics did you like
it yeah I like comics as well and a lot
of cartoons they accompany for me
me for almost my entire life when I was
a kid I was sitting in the TV every
Sunday morning at what's watching
cartoons for hours my parents really
didn't like it but I loved the cartoons
later on when I went to school I start
drawing little characters in my math
books in the corner and every time you
flip the page your characters came to a
life it was really amazing so my name is
Martin I'm a principal engineer at Xena
Shraddha I organized a meet-up here in
Berlin and I organized also a conference
later this year all based on around
angular I later on used my mouth books
for the original purpose and studied
math I love JavaScript I love the
possibilities that you can have of
JavaScript and I love cats that's
probably the reason why all over the
Internet
my cat's face is my avatar for Twitter
github everything and also my cat's
nickname chaos monster became my twitter
handle so if you ever see a cat like
this it's probably me I started as a
back-end developer and at some time in
late last 10 years I switched to the
front-end and became a JavaScript
developers I did that because I was
passionate about the UX possibilities
that you can have all the user
interaction that was possible in the
browser when angularjs 1.0 point 7 came
out years ago and I was like yes I want
to do everything in the browser because
I want to be close to the user I want to
have interaction with them but I was
really really afraid of animations every
time my product only came to me and said
something like
can you move that from the left to the
right I was like don't you think it
would be better if it just suddenly pops
up on the right side of the screen it's
way better it's way better and I don't
have to do animations so the time passed
by and I watched documentation by Studio
Ghibli's Studio Ghibli created those
amazing animes like my neighbor totoro
or the Moving Castle and this
documentation was about how they managed
to make walking animations such a smooth
experience such a natural experience for
everyone I almost like all the time I
learned from different domains from
other professions why don't I look at
cartoons and look can see what I can
learn about animations from watching
cartoons and learning how they do it so
if you do a little bit of research in
that field
you are not able to get around this book
it's called the illusion of life it's by
Frank Thomas and Ollie Johnston both of
them are animators at Disney and in the
80s when they release that book they
boiled down all the knowledge that
Disney acquired in the last fifty fifty
five decades not fifty decades five
decades when it did all this amazing
animation movies to 12 principles of
animation and I thought to myself after
reading them they are really amazing I
have a lot that I learned from that and
I boiled it down to the eighth principle
of web animation starting with squash
and stretch if you think about a ball a
tennis ball for example and if you think
how a tennis ball would behave if you
throw it on the floor and how it would
bounce back into the air you think about
it it wouldn't really change its its
form its shape it would look something
like this but that doesn't feel really
good because you can't feel the speed of
the ball you can't feel the impact of
the ball on the floor and you can't feel
how the ball falls jumps back to the air
so what you can do instead
is doing stretch and squash you use
stretch to show speed to show how the
ball gets accelerated and you use squash
to show how the ball gets pulled pushed
into the floor and how the energy goes
back into speed afterwards and you can
not only use that to create a ball that
bounces off a floor but you can also use
it to create a feeling for material this
box that is created with keyframes in
CSS feels really squashy it feels like
bouncy it gets adjectives it's it's not
just a box so you have to keep a few
things in mind when you do that for
example you have to think about the
volume the volume of the object should
not change because your brain recognizes
if you just change the volume of the
object by squashing or stretching it and
feels really off if you do that and you
can use squash and stretch to give
objects weight and to give objects a
feeling of speed and also to give them
material the feeling on how the material
works the second and the second
principle is anticipation if you look at
this stick figure you would think okay
what happens next you would not expect
it to just fly off in the air like this
it doesn't feel right right what you
actually want to do is you want it to
bend the knees and then go up because
with that you give the viewer of this
animation the feeling that something
will happen me if the user can
anticipate what happens next if I'm
going down and I'm jumping up you will
expect me to jump up because you've seen
me going to the floor and you expect
something to happen here and you can use
the same in the browser when you do some
wobbling animation before you do a
bigger animation before you show that
you can drag and drop it also really
important what I did not do here but
what can be really important for
anticipation is the timing
so if you slowly start winding up before
you do a really fast
throw the ball this is also important
not only the winding up but also the
speed of how I do it the third principle
is staging Frank and Ollie talked said
it's like that if you have a
presentation of an idea it should be
completely and unmistakably clear what
you want to do this means don't irritate
your audience your viewer your user by
pointing them in a certain direction and
then doing something totally different
look at this stage in all those arrows I
focus your your view onto one point on
the screen it must it doesn't have to be
the center of the screen but I focus
yours your view on one point of the
screen and you expect something to
happen here like a character appearing
like a magician and use that technique
wherever you do it if it's on the left
or on the right just use it to make it
clear for the user where something will
appear or something will happen the same
goes for when we are in the Western
culture we expect something that comes
from the left to the right to appear on
stage if it goes from the center to the
right we think it disappears from the
stage and if you drop it down to the
bottom of the stage you think it will
never come back keep those things in
mind because they are part of staging
when you look at this green div and I
want you to focus on that diff okay now
I told you to focus on the diff but
imagine you're a user and you're in a
browser and I want you as a developer to
focus on a diff is I can make the
background opaque and do a little bit of
animation for you to focus on that green
diff maybe it's a button maybe I want
you to save that form because otherwise
all your data will be gone number four I
have a little bit of a problem with that
because in animation this is a
really really important thing to do but
I wasn't sure how to translate it to the
web browser let's go a little bit back
if you have a motion in a in a movie or
an enemy you have a lot of pictures and
those pictures slightly change from
frame to frame normally we talk about 12
or 24 frames per second if you're a
gamer you know that you want to run on
60 frames per second meaning you want to
have so many images that slightly
differentiate which other in each second
and back in the days in the 1980s and
before that before this was a thing all
of those frames all of those images had
to be drawn by hand so people were
sitting there and draw the same image
over and over again and just slightly
make a change to the previous one and
here comes a technique of straight ahead
if you just change the the image just
slightly without any concept or any
story about it you just create something
that is randomly moving like fire or
rain or explosions this is a really
great technique to do that but if you
want to tell a story you need a concept
a storyboard behind that and for that
you think about what is my first pose
and then you think about what will be my
last pose and you think about what poses
are in between those two poses that are
important for me to show my audience so
the audience gets an understanding of
the movement we want to have and then
you create those keyframes and
afterwards you just add more and more
frames by using the straight-ahead
technique and at the end you have a
movement and with CSS we have CSS
transform we have scale rotate you name
it and we also have CSS keyframes and
this is where my mind just popped
I have those poses those are key
those are frames that are really
important for how the animation would
work same goes for web animation API and
if you look at keyframes and this is no
change to how web animations work with
the web animation API you create your
initial post you create your final post
and if you want to you create a few
poses in between that are important for
you to tell the story of how you object
moves and then you let the browser just
fill in all the other thousands of
frames that you may might want to have
the fifth principle of animations
defined by a Leon Frank is follow
through and overlapping action if I show
you this flower pot and I will tell you
that I move it from the right to the
left you would imagine that flower pot
to move and you would imagine the flower
to move follow through and overlapping
means that you can drag secondary
animations like the flower because the
flower takes a little bit longer than
the flower pot until its realizes that
something is moving and it takes a
little bit longer that just to physics
to realize that it stopped and this is
called follow through and overlapping
action and if you look at the browser I
found this great article you get two
slides afterwards and you I highly
recommend to read that article that was
mentioned that mentions how to fix drag
and drop by using a little bit of math
you see where while I was into that
article and what they do is they use the
mouse movement speed and translate it
into the tilt of the direct object the
faster Mouse moves the higher is the
angle of the object that hills and if
you mouse move slowly the tilt goes back
to her horizontal stage and this makes
all your drag-and-drop my animations
feel way more natural way more like I
want to drag and drop everything here
because it's awesome so in and slow out
I read that principle and it was like
yes I totally understand it I know how
this will work in the browser just for
you to present how it works slow in and
slow out means if I'm starting running
over there I won't start with full speed
and if I'm stopping at the end of the
stage I won't step stop at full speed I
will slow down this is a natural
movement I will show it to you just for
the sake that you see it I'm walking
really fast I'm slowing down and back I
start fast slowing down yeah I did my
sport for today
[Music]
I would never imagine that someone claps
when I'm running and we have the same
thing in the browser we call them easing
functions we call them busy functions if
you have a ease-in and ease-out function
on your animation it slowly starts it
becomes - it's it comes to it faster
speed and it slows down before its final
stage and if you do a linear
transformation
it will have the same speed from the
beginning till the end and this feels
really mechanical not natural like ease
in and out and mechanical is something
that we really don't have that often
even cars that it's mechanical would
slowly start only things like bullets
would be really fast from the beginning
secondary actions this is about how your
main action your main animation needs
some times support so you can tell a
story and for that you need a concept
and for example if I'm walking over that
side of the stage my arms are really
stiff and I'm walking and you see the
walking animation imagining that
animation and it feels really stiff and
really unnatural so what I actually do
when I walk and I probably all of you if
you're walking you move your upper body
you move your arms ok I'm a little bit
over accelerating now but in general you
move your body with that and the
movement of the arms and the shoulders
are your secondary actions and they
support the main animation meaning the
walking animation I found this really
really really awesome CSS animation by
Andrew Wong and I don't want you to
focus on a walking animation I want you
to focus on the secondary animations
here meaning the clouds in the back the
science in the back they are secondary
animations that help to give the
animation depth that helped to give your
relation to how fast this object is
moving and this helps you to understand
the main animation so secondary
animations are really really good when
it comes to how to improve your main
animation and with that I'm coming to
the eighth principle called appealing
Frank and Ollie just said make your
animations appeal make it make the
viewer feel like I love this character I
can totally take this character how it
works moves and I want to make that my
conclusion as well so here's my
conclusion of looking at the 12
principles of animation by Frank and
Ollie and how to translate them to the
to the web first use animations to
improve your use experience because
motion can tell a story and to tell a
story you need a storyboard
make yourself comfortable of the idea to
think about where does my animation
start what is - in between of my
animation and where does my animation
stop make us concept not only for one
animation but for the entirety of your
website think about how all the
animations can work together and please
don't overdo your animations because if
you do too much and it doesn't feel
really right and last but not least have
fun
have fun with doing animations because
animations are great and don't be afraid
as I was because there's so much content
about how to do animations look at the
12 principles of animation and learn
from over century of animations on how
to really do great animations thank you
for listening to me and thanks jazz
country you for giving the opportunity
to talk to you about animations
[Music]